トヨトミヒデユキ 天下一のぶっ飛びマシーン 千葉県出身
小田慎太郎 セオリー無視の一発屋 千葉県出身
徳川康兵衛 麻雀理論を全く持たない タコなき男 千葉県出身
明智光一 超合理的理論麻雀を打つ 試合校舎 千葉県出身
はやみあきな一応トヨテミの恋人
驚異的な月の持ち主
千葉県出身
はーい
どなた
トヨタミ君
また麻雀であの三人に負けたのね
私間違ってたわ
私トヨタミ君に麻雀なんかやめてって言ったけど
それは所詮、逃げだったのよ。
あの人たちに負けたまま引き下がったら、
あなたは一生ダメ人間の楽園を押されてしまうわ。
ツカンポ?
だから、男として彼らに一死を報いてやんなきゃ。
あれ?
そ、それはあの有名な、ツカンポの花?
ツカンポ。
豊臣くん、ちょっと私に付き合って。
ここは
私の友達のプロジャンシー
井出さんの道場よ
やあ早見くん久しぶり
この人が東大出身の僕に特訓を受けたいという
豊臣くんですか
ええよろしくお願いします
わかりました
東大出身の僕が必ず豊臣くんを
無敵の最強ジャンシーに育て上げてみせましょう
やだ、やだ、あきらえちゃん
トヨタミ君、頑張ってね
何ですか、この部屋は
君には話してなかったかもしれないが、実は僕、東大出てるんだ
散々聞いてますって
これから君に、東大出身の僕がプログラミングしたコンピューターマージャンで
その基礎を養ってもらおう
何だ?ただの麻雀ゲームじゃん
確かに今まで麻雀ゲームと呼ばれるものは山ほどあった
しかしどれもこれも麻雀の持っている芸術性理論性を再現できていない
そこら辺の学校をポッと出たような学歴の低い愚民どもが作っていたからだ
僕脱がせ麻雀の方がいいな
バカモン!そんなことだから君は麻雀に強くなれないんだ
東大での僕が一番正しいのだー!
などは分かりました!やります!やります!
言うだけあって本格的だな。
よーし、勝ってやる。親はトイメンのイデプロか。
ドラガン2枚。
へー、割といい手だぞ。
テンゴフォーリュウイリソウ
な、なんなんですかこのゲーム
東大出身の僕はコンピューターの中でも常にパーフェクトでなくてはならないのだ
こっちの方がよっぽどクソゲーだよ
テンゴフォーリュウイリソウ
うーん
はい
一歩ずつの大損が
くそー
昨日の夜からぶっ通しで2627回もこれを
よーし
では特訓第二弾に移ろう
今度は一体何
これは東大出身の僕が考案した精神力強化マシーンだ
精神力強化マシーン?
これから君に仮想現実麻雀を体験してもらう
君はその映像を瞬きせずに見続けなくてはならない
スタッフともできないよ
それを見た君の精神状態はここに波長となって現れる
では早速始めよう
どう?
レンタッピン三色、インペイコー!
あらほう、ひめはれ。
その椅子は電気椅子になっていて、君の精神波が乱れた途端、100万ボルトの電流が流れる仕組みになっている。
そ、そんな!
電撃を受けたくなかったら精神波を乱すな。強い精神力なくして麻雀に勝利はない!
どうし!
一発ツモ!
100万だ!
大三拳!
超精神!
フジホー!
ツリーソン!
神童刀!
スーパーアップフォー
リュウイーション
オクシムソー
ローン
よし、成功だ
トヨタミくーん
やったわね
トヨタミくん
1ヶ月もの間
イデさんのところでよく頑張ったわ
トヨタミくん
何を話しかけても無駄だ
今の彼の頭の中は
麻雀に勝つということだけでいっぱいで
それ以外のことには何も反応しない
マシーンだ
くだらない感情は一切捨て、冷静かつ合理的に着々と手を進める。
彼は麻雀を打つためのマシーンに生まれ変わったんだ。
人格まで変えてくれなんて頼まなかったわ!
勝つためなんだよ。
より多くの犠牲を払った者が最後には勝ち残るんだ!
そんな…
私は東大でだ!
ええええええ
勝負だ
アンバー、おめえから誘うなんていい度胸してんね
おい、こいついつもと目つきが違うぞ
ケツ負けんでねえか、おめえ
あ、始まるわ
私は灯台でだ
何だこの異様なリーパイの速さは
この手
5、6、7の3色をあくまで狙うなら
ツーソギリ
しかし
それではその後の待ちが狭く
デメリットが大きすぎる
6、7、8狙いに決めてウーアンギリ
これは最も手が広く
たとえウーピンを引いたとしても
ウウソギリ。ドラスジリーチでマンガンを期待できる。
最後にウウソギリだが、これはウパーピンサブロウソ引きと極端に手が狭められる反面、
あくまで両方の3色を両天秤にかけられる。
しかし、パーソ引きで3色を6、7、8に移行するときには一手遅れてしまう。
とはいえ、ここはアンコのウウソを早切りしておくのが最善手。
え?ウウソギリ?
安心しろ彼はマシーンだ
灰を持ってから切るまでわずか0.5秒の間に100万通りの可能性を計算し尽くし
その中で最善の手を打つ
トヨタミ君
ラーン
三色同行三暗号タイヤをドラサン
バイバンダー
ズガーン
あったった!どこが最善の手なのよ!
これぐらい計算済みだ
彼をよく見てみたまえ
確かに、いつものように図鑑とは言ってるものの、態度は冷静そのものだわ
じゅんちゃん三色、ピンフイペーコー!
図鑑
ラッキー ピンフー リャンペーコー ドラドラ
ズガン リーチ
リーチ一発 シーズイッツ ドライチダンベ
ズガン
これはマシーンだ
え?
確実に高めに振り込む精密度
振り込んでも振り込んでも動じない耐久力
ま、まさか
そう、彼は今
世界最強、かけねなしの
振り込みマシーンだ
東大出身麻雀師井出によって
完璧なまでの振り込みマシーンに改造されてしまった豊臣
不安
第3弦
果たして彼に社会復帰の時はやってくるのであろうか
がっぱれ豊臣
うもう
一等のスキー旅行一等のスキー旅行
はい残念でした四等ティッシュペーパーだめだこりゃ
ずが
よいしょおらせ
100万
あら豊臣くん
あきなちゃん
よーし
おめでとうございます
やったわ
さすが!あきなちゃん!すごいすごい!
それじゃあ、豊臣くん、滑ろっか!
うん!
それ!
豊臣くん!早く!
今、行くよ!レッツゴー!
レッツゴー!
あたっ!
まあ、豊臣くんったら!
明菜ちゃん、なんて可愛いんだろう!
でも、二人っきりでスキーってことは、アフタースキーも当然!
先に行くわよ、豊臣くん!
二人っきりね、豊臣くん。
二人っきりだね、アキナちゃん。
私、ちょっと酔っちゃったみたい。
じゃあ、もう寝ようか。アキナちゃん。
ちょっと行けないわ。トヨタミ君だな。
アキナちゃん。
この声!
おい!どいつくれ!どいつくれ!どいつくれ!どいつくれ!
ドンドンドン ドンドンドン ドンドンドンドン...
今のは確か...
テロ!
トヨタミじゃねェか
えっ?
つづるぅぬぬ
ヘラじゃぃぃぃやーちょ
ヘアー、ホント
偶然だよな
同じ宿で隣同士の部屋なんてさ
お前ら後尽きてきたな
なーに言ってるんだよ
同じ商店街で当てたスキー旅行だろ
同じペンションになるのは当然だよ
なにーこいつらも
ねーこれでアフタースキーもぐっと盛り上がるがやな
おーじゃあ早速
あきれいじゃん
おらら甘えんじゃねーよ
おーそ男には男の世界があるだよ
ポンだ
ポンだよ
アンダーチュンモッポンだ
あ、リーチ
止まんねえ
スーアップ
あ、すげえこいつ
名付けて直角コマジャンダイ
テンパったけどスーソーは切れない
ここは着実に暴言打法
二人に現物!
甘いな。
ヤスの虚空を避け、シンタロウの樹氷をかわす華麗な回し打ち!
パラレル打法だ!
ラン!
太陽三尺、ドライチ!
ズガー!
ズガン。
ズガン、ズガン、ズガン、ズガン、ズガン、ズガン、ズガン、ズガン、ズガン、ズガン!
ズガー!
何だ、トヨタミ。またラスカ?
トヨタミ君、代わって!
あたしと変わって
あきなちゃんじゃ無理だよ
豊臣くんよりはマシよ
まあ、そりゃ言えるわな
うつべ、うつべ、オラとうつべ、一緒にうつべ、うちうちするべよ
やす、よだれふけよ
いいよ、葉一杯だな
自廃から切ってと
こうね
そうね
あ、あたしペイのトイツ切っちゃったんだ
あら、またペイだわ
そっか、上がりだわ
いやね、最初から上がってたのに
トヨタミ君たら教えてくれないんだもの
はいはい、ラッキー
ツモドライチは1000点オールね
きゃー、わーい。ほら見て見て、豊臣くん。
あれ?倒れちゃった。
そいつ、気弱いから。
いいもん。私一人でやるもん。リーチ!
ついてるからな。
えいっ!一発ツモ!
なんちゃって。ダメか。
あははは、ったく、そんなに一人でつきまくられてたまるだかも。
って、あ、あははは、悪い悪い、パイがくっついてただよ。
でー、ピンフー、リャンペーコー、ドラドラか、チートイッツ、ドラドラ、どっちにするべえかな、これなあなあなあ。
スーピンは女のツモだったなあ。
でー、こっちでレジだ。
は?
でー、羽も。
キャッ!積もった!
ほら!
あだ、スチーピンのシャボー。ピキン。
タコマチじゃん。
えっと、リーズモで、これはトイトイかな。
リーズモ?
トイトイ?
あともこんな時間か。
ああ、そろそろ寝なくったな。
まいった、まいった。お肌にフィークス。
おっと、また。
お前、気絶してたんじゃなかったの?
そうだよ。してろよ。
ふう、気絶。なんのことでしょうね。
部屋に帰るんなら、一万六千オール払ってからにしてもらいましょうか。
さあ、アキナちゃん。ここで一気に負けを取り戻すんだ。
チャッチャッチャン。チャッチャッチャン。チャッチャッチャン。
ほれ、アキナ。アキナ。
もう、調子いいんだから。
やった!ドブトンドラさん、天敗!
リーチ!
えぇ、うそ!
なんだ?直角光!
出た!カンちゃん!
リーチ一発!ドブトンドラさん!
ウラドラ六万ついて、親の倍満!
カッチン カッチンだ
ラン スマ ラン スマ ラン スマ
ラン スマ ラン スマ
強えな あの女
生きなし30万点のトップだぞ
いや すごいよ アキラちゃん
2人がコンビを含めば 迎えたから敵だしさ
豊臣くん 私もう眠い
寝てもいい?
いいよ あと僕やるから
いくら豊臣くんでも30万点あれば大丈夫よね
悪いけど後は頼むわ
当たり前さ
こっからこいつらに負けるはずないじゃん
楽勝楽勝
豊臣
俺たち相手に楽勝だと
おめえには絶対負けねえだ
怖いなみんな
でも30万点の差は簡単に縮まりはしないよ
ローン!
メンタンピン3色
たったの8000点
30万にはまだ遠いな
遠いもん何も
もうトップ決まってんだって
いい加減諦めて
2着を目指すんだね
はい
ローン!
名本ダブトン
ちくしょう
跳ねないか
せめてドラ欲しかったな
1万2000ポンチ
大したことない
ないさ
ローン!ちいといドラドラ!
ダブルンダイ!ツイドラドラ!
おっと、もうこんな時間か。
明日は早いから、僕もう寝るね。
ちょ、ええと待たんかい!
勝ち逃げは許さねえだ!
寝るんだったら、あと半ちゃん十回は打ってもらうぜ。
こうして、豊臣の地獄のアフタースキーの夜は更けてゆくのでありました。
ああ、あの甘いアキナと過ごす人形の夢は、今、何処?
おはよう、豊臣くん。
あら?
違う。
ま、まさか。
豊臣くんのバカ!
違う。
トヨタミくんよりあたしのほうが なんだかずっとつきがあるみたい
あたしもこれからは マージャンサクサクっとやってみるドラッガー
あれ やだ うつっちゃった
次回 スーパーズガン
カッパギズガンと アキナふたたび
きっと見てね
ねむちゃや
インターネットスター・スターズ・ミナミ・ハロー!
勝負かけたら紫を横の狙い撃ち
君はアゲマの主席じゃないか
僕とワンガンつぼろうよ
つかんと幸せつかもうと
スーパースーパー
気合でやるまんまくところ
飛んで
さあ
ここは3年待ちどころ
ゆくべかんきゃん くしむそぼも くせきがはだ
すぼうにぃ ぼうま けんくうにぃ やりぬいて
かって のめごす ビールが うまい
スカッと おたかは いのちがけ
スカッと スカッと がきかけた
だかんらんらんらん
ご視聴ありがとうございました